here's the thing we train our whole  entire lives  for a couple small moments so for me i  trained for 15 years  i got to go to the ncaa's twice the girl  that leah thomas finished in front of  you have no idea how long she trained  you have no idea the number of hours we  put into this stuff  for a couple moments that we get guys we  don't  we don't make money there's not a lot of  money in women's sport and so for shitty  athletes that never really want anything  anyway former athletes that aren't  competing today and then to say oh  it's fine it's only one race it's only  one division it's a horrible take  because it's not you losing the  opportunity it's us  and we train our entire lives for this  [ __ ]